qu'est ce qui s'est passé et coûte alors
c'était à moissac zemmour venait et bien
enregistré un nouveau ralliement celui
du maire du rassemblement national il
sort donc de sa voiture légère
défaillance du service d'ordre puisque
celui qui me tient la portière fait
partie du sdlp donc du ministère il est
rattaché au ministère de l'intérieur est
il en train de serrer la main du chef du
deuxième cordon de sécurité autour des
règlements et il arrive c'est fou c'est
l'arrivée du cv du service d'ordre local
donc les deux hommes en gros ont un
moment et bien d'inattention et c'est à
ce moment là qu eric zemmour se fait
écraser 7,9 sur le crâne alors on va
vous dire tout ce qui s'est passé parce
qu'on a envie de savoir ce qui s'est
passé après c'est ça en fait le truc
aussi qui est d'abord parce que là on a
vraiment les foules et coulisses de ce
qui s'est passé après antoine de dire je
sais vous avez des informations et nous
aussi d'ailleurs je crois que gilles a
des infos enfin il va les avoir recours
l'émission
antoine qu'est ce qui s'est passé après
trois mois qu'ils ont beaucoup discuté
ensemble mais déjà moi je trouve qu eric
zemmour a eu une bonne réaction eric
zemmour dit bon on va pas poursuivre ce
monsieur je soyez là s'en lasse pas
alors et combiné truc moi la place
d'eric zemmour j'aurais voulu déposer
plainte
et c'est parce que c'est agaçant il a
discuté avec zemmour dit je dépose pas
plainte si ce monsieur fait ce geste
c'est qui doit vouloir dire quelque
chose et donc eric zemmour a fait sortir
ce monsieur de garde à vue et puis exe
mot a rencontré ce monsieur a déçu ce
monsieur veut dire que si vous les
voulez faire une omelette sera non ce
monsieur il saisit ainsi que les
politiques ne nous écoute jamais
d'accord je ne sais pas comment réussir
non mais ça aurait été un homme
politique un autre homme politique il
aurait fait pareil probablement
non j'ai discuté ici une histoire alors
c'est quoi le monsieur a expliqué qu'il
avait un enfant handicapé le prix n'a
été choqué par les propos d'eric zemmour
sur l'inclusion des enfants handicapés à
l'école et d'ailleurs c'était le
j'imagine le sujet de l' échange entre
les deux une fois qu'il l'a fait venir à
son meeting à agen pour discuter avec
lui quelles sont dans le sud ni vraiment
je savais pas comment réussir à parler
et donc j'ai fait ça après il dit que
c'était une connerie il s'est excusé
vis-à-vis d'eric zemmour et puis ils ont
pu échanger sur la situation du fils
handicapé de ce monsieur et la
discussion elle a porté sur mais la
façon dont les médias ont largement
rapportées déformé les propos d'eric
zemmour jusqu'à ce monsieur est donc ce
monsieur était persuadé qu eric zemmour
vous les empêchez empêcher son fils
d'aller à l'école mais c'est pas ça qui
règlera dit eric zemmour a dit l'école
n'est pas toujours la meilleure solution
n'est pas toujours la solution la plus
adaptée pour les enfants en situation de
handicap et une fois qu'ils ont pu
expliquer ça le monsieur a dit bah je
comprends mieux votre point de vue
maintenant est donc vraiment ça pose la
question de la façon dont dans les
médias les propos d'eric zemmour le plus
souvent peuvent être transformés lancer
un match est à sens il est question un
petit peu
difficile
c'est un monsieur de 70 ans est ce que
si ça avait été
notre personnel et répondre un janus
répondre tout de suite et ce cas alors
c'est quoi vous avez 17 avr question
look si ça avait une autre personne un
jeune un peu un petit peu plus petits
pays bas ou maghrébins vers l'amérique
arrêté lui parler après pour l'expliquer
quand il a été dans le même
arrondissement où il s'est fait insulter
par le mec que j'ai condamné d'abord le
mec qui a condamné car insultes et eric
zemmour j'étais pas d'accord sur ce
qu'il avait fait il avait insulté règle
est mort il avait filmé eric zemmour il
a porté plainte le gars a pris trois
mois de prison avec sursis donc il avait
été condamné pour quoi là quand ça un
mec avec un béret on va parler avec lui
et pourquoi quand c'est un autre mec qui
l'insultent qui est pas d'accord c'est
quoi le degré de l'insulteur quand on
insulte tu portes plainte et quand on te
jette un oeuf tu va discuter avec le mec
c'est ça que j'arrive n'a en fait le
monsieur a vraiment dit assez vite aux
policiers mais je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
fait ça moi je voulais lui parler et une
fois actualisées ça ne lavera entendu ça
il a dit je suis
d'accord on va parler je suis rentrée
dernière la référence que vous faites
vous la connaissez la référence oui mais
le monsieur voulait pas parler du tout
il n'était pas d'accord elle est en
désaccord et zemmour d'hommes se laisse
référence non mais la d2 en désaccord la
différence c'est que ce monsieur là il
voulait vraiment parler du dans la
discussion a eu lieu et ils ont pu se
parler
on parle tout va beaucoup mieux le
garder l'auteur a été immédiatement
interpellé par les gendarmes et placé en
garde à vue et en garde à vue tout le
monde s'est rendu compte les gendarmes
qui l'interrogeait que c'était une
démarche individuelle d'un père un peu
désespéré donc ils ont sollicité régler
mots pour savoir s'il voulait porter
plainte parce qu'il faut savoir que
c'est passible de poursuites et eric
zemmour et ses équipes ont tout de suite
dit si c'est une démarche individuelle
c'est un monsieur assez âgé pour
répondre à votre question dont on ne
portera pas plainte il peut revenir et
nous allons discuter donc il a bien joué
politiquement ou qu'ils ont discuté
ensemble ils ont en même temps ils ont
discuté en france parmi les sept minutes
bref vous avez toujours un chrono et le
gars il a toujours un oeil à turin qu'on
attend
alors oui donc sept minutes un peu moins
de dix minutes d'accord règlement avait
un train ensuite si c'était la fin de
son discours avant que le dialogue était
cordiale j'ai pas assisté au dialogue on
a rapporté c'est effectivement le
monsieur lui a présenté des excuses et
ensuite le sujet était l'inclusion des
enfants handicapés à l'école et en fait
il a précisé son propos près de
exactement de ce monsieur sait très bien
ce que j'aime moi ce que je voudrais
quand même j'aurais parlé comme d'un
truc c'est la sécurité parce que là la
c1 neuf ça
dans la nuque c'est pas scandaleux ils
sont 15 autour de lui
ça ne va pas on va pas on va pas leur
jeter la pierre mal parce que ça c'est
moi je sais pas j'ai jamais assez
hommage voilà
williams et ben c'est sûr mais ces
marchés que ses complices les baptise
ramdam est au chômage c'est une question
de grosse remise en question il arrive
même pas en courant ils arrivent
tranquillement
il sort un couteau c'est la même chose
voilà
j'ai tapé sur zemmour pour saluer ce
café zemmour parce que monsieur d'un
enfant sur le handicap quand même bien
cerner ces sujets avec lui mais votre
service de sécurité dites-leur ladite
leur eau mais quand même ça pourrait
parler et que le monsieur a voulu mettre
en avant c'est qu'ils se retrouvent très
seuls à devoir porter son fils de treize
pas votre place n'est pas la vraie vie
c'est mérité problème le problème
monsieur secure en france je vous rend
il faut être mal frappe fort dans la
parole ils cassent à l'after quelqu'un
du court lui donne la parole l'autre
hymne une gifle président du coup la
presse le donnent la parole donc en fait
je connais l'homme en train de dire elle
s'est comportée vous mal et où vous
donnant
les sujets
c'était petit et que tu sers à rien on
s'en fout on reste entre l'élite les
hommes politiques qui restent dans
l'élite il n'écoute pas les petits gens
ils en ont rien à [ __ ] des petits
jours les réseaux qui sera élu il
faut dénoncer toutes les violences même
les petites violences dont la raison la
raison s'est passé par le social tu vas
bien sûr suis d'accord mais pour avoir
discuté avec ce monsieur pour avoir
entendu la conversation entre eric
zemmour et sociaux j'ai vraiment vu le
sujet mais ça c'est parce que c'est les
sujets quand est venue en france où il
est venu avec ses sept voitures qui pèse
trois tonnes chacun savait faire un
scandale pas possible avec tout son
service de sécurité parce qu'il avait
dit à l'époque j'étais président les
services de sécurité en france je n'y
crois pas bien il a bien raison en
france le président prend une barbe les
candidats seraient peut être un couteau
n'importe quoi les services de sécurité
français sont désastreux et c'est ça
qu'il faut dire surtout d âme trade à
condition qu'un derrière tu seras but
atteint enfants handicapés sera plus le
chômage peu importe c'est très triste
mais c'est pas ça le sujet non mais
alors justement de ce que je vais
revenir sur cet axe nuages sur le fait
que le monsieur était libéré vous
comprenez où vous trouvez non vous
comprenez donc pardon je suis désolé
parce qu'encore une fois on est soixante
dix ans mais oui je suis désolé mais je
suis désolé maintenant je suis désolé il
faut porter mes petits groupes des
moulins il faut qu'il soit condamné
comme le gamin kevin qu'une blacks au
président qu'à
prison je suis désolé yahia ben alaya
lord il ya des choses ya des règles et
au talent des lumignons ne dit pas
quelque chose en frappant ya des vols
ont fait des choses pour sa main je suis
désolé la sqaf eric zemmour est bien
cette règle
peut frapper le problème dans l'autre
sens mathieu imaginons que ce monsieur
est interpellé eric zemmour de loin il
est pas fait ça est ce qu'ils auraient
pu avoir le sourire est pas encore là
mais ils ont eu comme alors pour vous
êtes d'accord et moi que non je suis pas
d'accord et que mathieu moi je trouve
que cette image et les violentes mellal
à la hauteur de la violence de certains
propos que tient eric zemmour est ce
monsieur peut-être que c'est vrai eric
zemmour a tenu ces propos sur le
handicap et sur les personnes en
situation de handicap il s'est peut-être
senti agressé malheureusement quand vous
avez un homme politique comme eric
zemmour qui parle à la télé les gens ne
peuvent pas répondre
sa manière il faut aussi se poser une
question pourquoi c'est à chaque fois
avec eric zemmour qui a des dérapages je
ne justifie
qu'il est président il ya toujours eu
des dérapages et quelques jours toujours
quelque chose c'est le candidat les
petits cela est tout le temps à insulter
qui s'est encore pour la partie je ne
justifie pas les violences et posez vous
les bonnes questions sur vos propos qui
sont extraits n'est la langue et de tous
les pays d'europe concernant des yeux
sur des coups et des claques dans la
figure tout ça fait rire tous les mois
moi je n'aime pas beaucoup ce
raisonnement on a le droit tout dire
eric zemmour ne dérape pas il dit les
choses non mais en fait là votre
raisonnement c'est il s'est fait
agresser il l'a bien cherché si on
commence à appliquer ça a causé la
minijupe de la loi
je suis d'accord avec toi
tolérer aucune agression aucune et eric
zemmour n'appelle pas plus d'agressions
paix si les rames pas penser les
condamne leur je vous le disais c'est la
façon dont beaucoup de personnes
rapportent à des formes les propos
d'eric zemmour eric zemmour c'est
quelqu'un de parfait état mais
n'importe quoi il est payé pour le
rappel à l'ordre en permanence il veut
l'ordre l'ordre bon lukas à 9 sur la
tête et portent pas plainte et c'est
bien ce qui fait
en pêche pas d'êtres humains d'armes
zemmour c'est la lionderie a pas
d'humanité
vous autour de la table qui aurait voulu
ce qui est du de l'avis de mathieu
supprimerait des petites pancartes
québec mathieu avait une nature parce
qu'ils ne la vie de mathieu oui répond
moi je suis de son avis parce que c'est
justement ce candidat qui prône la zéro
tolérance qui dit que si tu t'appelles
moi-même brahimi youssoupha tu dois te
tenir tranquille et tu dois pas les
jeter des regards mais comme ça ne soit
pas de merci comme un rat au débat si
des gens mais perd tu ne veux pas que
des appels comme c'est arrivé et c'est
lui qui prône la tolérance zéro niveau
j'ai boxé situation maintenant raconte
le broker les cauchemars mais parce que
vous dites n'importe quoi à n'en sais
rien je ne veux pas vous les séries on
espère examen des gens mohamed il
proposait qu'eric zemmour qu'on arrête
les gens mois m vous sous-entendez qu'il
fait je le rappelle est l'égérie comme
j'aime
me laisser leur est faite jardin projet
pas posé de questions
j'aimerais poser de questions si vous
avez
élaboré pour la monstration de ce que je
vous
dis le relais moi je suis vraiment
choqué par ce que disait guillaume c'est
à dire que pour lui parce que c'est eric
zemmour on peut les envoyer des e sur la
terre du tout hein mr bah si je vous
fait 17 tués dans
des violences
jeudi qu'il faut se remettre en question
mais comprend faty culièrement haineux
et qu'il ya des gens qui vivent ça comme
une violence et une aguichante qui
répondent avec le rhume grippe a
mais tous étaient contents pourquoi pas
les impôts américains c6100 même temps
mathieu c'est quoi la limite entre 1,9
et pourquoi pas la prochaine fois je
suis pas d'accord zamora pour américain
allons-y mais moi je rejoins ce que tu
dis puisque en fait c'est le seul moyen
de se faire entendre pour ces gens là
par saddam eternal d'accord guillaume
ces
questions de manière simple et souple
est ou s'il vous plaît est-ce que c'est
pas aussi un coup médiatique mais bien
sûr
si il avait demandé que l'homme soit
condamné lourdement vous aurez vous
auriez dit regza moore exagère et s'est
alors demandé moore fait preuve
d'humanité il dit bon bah je vais
discuter avec ce monsieur et là vous
dites c'est un coup médiatique en fait
on a l'impression qu'à tous les coûts
opèrent ici les insultes
imaginez il s'est dit il vaut mieux
discuter je suis monsieur et donc moi je
trouve vraiment que la réaction d'eric
zemmour est la bonne alors servi excusez
moi antoine mais là je vous comprends
pas du tout ce soir chanteuse avait une
posture et un positionnement qui est
complètement incompréhensible d'abord
vous arriver et vous dit non mais de
toute façon si c'était quelqu'un d'autre
que et mourinho rio si l'oeuf déjà non
on comprend très bien toulouse et le non
non non le fait parce que il a dit ça
sur les enfants handicapés concrètement
qui s'est pris un oeuf sur la tête donc
déjà bonne posture de dédé le départ est
malhonnête et ensuite excusé moi avoue
victimiser zemmour alors que zemmour est
une bête médiatique c'est une bête de
scène et c'est exactement ce qu'ils
disent comment il le dit donc sa sortie
sans répondant qu'elle savait pas qu'il
allait prendre un bonheur non mais ça va
venir écouter l'avis sur les enfants dit
avait il fait très bas mais on n'est pas
là dessus
j'aime la question chez nous et questure
et au fond du top et il n'a rien dit
mauvais
les enfants handicapés c'est pas exact
et vous voyez c'est précisément parce
que sur les plateaux vous dit il a dit
quelque chose de mauvais ce qui n'est
pas vrai que ce monsieur il croit que
là je réagis j'entends à l'instant eric
zemmour a dit quelque chose de mauvais
sur les enfants il a dit qu'il était
prêt mais il a dit qu' on ne pouvait pas
avoir un accueil satisfaisant à l'école
normale pour tous les enfants handicapés
et que parfois il fallait des
établissements adaptés et ce monsieur
est dit si seulement il n'y a pas d'état
d'âme sable lavé tradition si j'ai une
question de santé antoine chaîne
question est également gauthier on se
rappelle qu'en emmanuel macron avait été
fait eric zemmour avait dit un truc
comme il a ce qu'il mérite ouais les
gars oui alors il avait dit aussi la
démocratie a été giflée exactement et
donc c'est vrai qu'ils sont nés réjouit
c'est la violence alors il veut toujours
la sécurité ils prônent la violence donc
là qu'est ce qu'on réponde à ça là je
crois que le meilleur exemple qui l'a
donné c'est pas déposé plainte et dire
on va discuter répond dépasser son
adversaire politique vit la même chose
avec la violence emmanuel macron avait
eu une volonté de discuter avec ce
monsieur on l'aurait tout salut et 90
jours est libre maintenant dans le monde
des barons non là bas alors on discute
non mais oui c'est vrai que les séries
dès que vous dénoncez la mairie l'a fait
mais là antoine ont là excusez moi avec
tout le respect que j'ai pour vous là
vous nous pipeauté si elle a entièrement
raison sur le coup médiatique d'eric
zemmour et vous savez très bien comment
ça s'est passé vous tout le monde autour
d'eric zemmour s'est rendu compte de
l'opportunité fait de partir de cet acte
de violence de faire un coup médiatique
attendez je vais parler avec lui devant
les caméras bien sûr après après après
là il a raison sur un truc c'est que
s'il n'avait pas fait ça est en fait
cotiser
coup je pense qu'il serait rentré rester
dans sa ligne de conduite ce qui est
l'ordre lors
white mais ça a un mec de ceux réalisant
aussi un enfant auquel cas possible
j'aurais dit c'est dégueu mini-série ses
députés mais si elle doit cesser oui
mais la loi c'est la loi le jeu on a
pris une bonne raison qu'elles aussi
sont ils si jal a tous à coeur
la photo avec ces deux là comme we
will c'est un chômeur en fin de droits
c'est aussi triste qu'un homme qui a
depuis indiqué
antoine qui se voudrait dire
moi je m'attends chose je pense qu'eric
zemmour n'a pas réfléchi mais il s'est
d'abord dit bah oui s'il a 70 ans un
enfant handicapé qu'il est fatigué
petites retraites 2
d'agriculteurs je veux le rencontrer ce
monsieur il doit y avoir une souffrance
immense et donc moi vraiment je trouve
que le candidat a fait preuve d'humanité
et ça vous surprend tellement parce que
vous êtes fait débat il ne devrait pas
avoir du made in usa c'est de donner une
image c'est lui qui nous a rendu cet
hymne à la tolérance zéro par rapport à
la violence et les missions territoire
français c'est lui qui me l'a dit parce
qu'il vaut mieux avoir son avis moi en
fait cet acte en lui même je comprends
et j'ai évidemment beaucoup de
compassion pour le monsieur en revanche
je trouve que ça envoie un très très
mauvais message parce que ça veut dire
qu' il faut faire de la violence pour se
faire écouter par la politique c'est une
brèche il peut être très dangereuse donc
l'acte en soit me prendre à 9 sur la
tête on peut dire c'est pas une grosse
violence que mais voilà et et le
monsieur aux six mètres à 9 sur
quelqu'un bon voilà c'est pas une grosse
violence mais ça montre une faille et ça
aurait pu être un couteau et ça va
peut-être donner des idées aux autres en
dix ans ce ne sont pas tellement avancé
qu'il était c'est très facile j'y vais
donc moi les deux messages des deux
côtés je trouve ça très grave beaucoup
plus grave que le lancer d'un oeuf voilà
gauthier non mais vous l'avez dit le but
c'était très clairement de jouer le
contraste avec emmanuel macron j'ai même
entendu bernard montiel cité l'exemple
du pape avec son agresseur ça même été
un exemple cité par une personne très
proche d'eric zemmour donc oui c'est
aussi évidemment de la communication on
attend résidentiel ancien surprend
personne ah oui évidemment c'est sa
revanche face à cc c'est normal louis
guilloux enjeux bon sans doute votre
ville non mais je pense que la violence
et le prix de physique mais elle peut
être aussi verbale et je pense que quand
on est un homme politique on a des
responsabilités qu'on parle à des
millions de gens il ya certains propos
qui peuvent être vécus comme une
agression et comme de la violence
ce n'est pas cautionner la violence
sauf ce soit depuis le début de
l'émission tu es à l'envers sur tous les
sujets pardon mais à la defa tig était
vraiment fatigué et on perd du disque
est en train de montrer zemmour en plus
cela a un sens c'est que finalement
comme tous les hommes politiques si
demain il est élu et bien finalement il
n'applique rappaz est bien la loi bah si
comme il l'avait dit avant puisque c'est
un homme qui veut l'ordre c'est un homme
qui veut voilà la tolérer l'intolérable
j'ai finalement mais il se rend compte
que il fait du cas par les a finalement
pour les agressions que je vois pas déjà
c'était la même chance c'est le droit de
la victime de choisir de déposer plainte
c'est bien ce que je dis mais le parquet
après fait appliquer la grève à
l'appliquer marqué les flotteurs
sérieuses comme tard qu'il va faire
excellent doit
penser que dans toute l'europe la presse
étrangère et c'est mon cas pardon mais
bien dans toute l'europe on est le seul
pays où les présidents les candidats
sont giflé par eni e.on et grotesque
mais même les autres chefs d'état que
dix viennent chez nous bien avec un
service de sécurité votre argument la
justice va statuer c'est pas parce que
et l'hexagone n'a pas déposé parce que
la justice ne faut ne suivra pas son
cours donc direction lui et dans un
geste d'apaisement dit je ne dépose pas
plainte et le parquet flottant vague à
la fois dans un geste d'apaisement et en
même temps pour écrire une histoire
parce que vous nous racontez une
histoire aussi c'est du storytelling
politique est en train de faire beaucoup
d'urgences tous ceux qui sont pas
contentes quelque chose à les y agresser
agressé des candidats et la presse nous
donnera la parole c'est ce qu'on est en
train de diriger rebelles non
monsieur je me suis là 70 ans voulait
vraiment ce monsieur aille en prison
pour 61 veille
mais
c'était très bien mais enfin mathieu
vous rendez compte moi c'est une hérésie
j'espère que le parquet ne se saisira
pas d'une enquête sur ce monsieur
pour une fois dans body d'empathie du
mali c'est toi qui les dix sept ans et
100 mais aimer le foot mais la loi c'est
la loi arrêtez vous êtes malade mais non
je suis désolé mon attelle vous allez
mettre ce monsieur en prison
alors 4ème citoyenneté oui c'est très
différent si leur effet à 24 ans il
aurait été plus jeunes là en revanche
n'aurait pas été un stage je suis toi tu
étais dans une ferme
[Musique]
sur le cap à la maison faisant escale à
kelly bédouine et me rend dingue sous
prétexte que les gens sont âgés ils
peuvent frapper les gens y merci insulté
lors tout faire je l'avais déjà dit on
m'avait tuer pour dire ça mais je vais
le redire c'est pas parce que tu es
vieux que tu dois frapper ouvrir sa
bouche en fait c'est comme les autres tu
es jeune tu es vieux tu feras pas les
gens tuent les tapas et la valeur du
compath excusé en fait pas une excuse
donc si c'est un jeune homme est basse
et seles et les mêmes conséquences si
c'est un vieux sait même pas si c'est la
syrie situation
antoine vous avez eu peur quand même ou
pas sur le moment on se demande ce qui
se passe et une fois qu'on voit eric
zemmour debout avec un hareng ce qui
vient de se passer on se dit mais la
prochaine fois ce sera même pas neuf
mais non mais en fait c'était pour ça
qu'il faut porter plainte mais non mais
vraiment non mais pardon c'est vrai ce
que je dis c'est un caillou ça serait
cool quand le sentiment que vous espérez
la violence mois jeunesse resort
fois la combattre il faut envoyer les
gilles fau de porter plainte évoqué une
justice et choqué par les images
évidemment comme j'avais été le seul
show tel background gifle président et
le président baré voulait pas porter
plainte mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce
pays mais en fait mais le parquet la
justice derrière phrase qui mais je me
fous du parquet nous parle de zemmour la
porte car larry derrière il ne fait pas
appliquer lui ce qu'il est en train de
lire ça c'est bien toi réseau de relance
en france est
qualifiée malgré la quatre mois de
prison faire suer rien sait rien elle
est venue ici
il a été voté
quatre mois 100 km